the new Morrison planetarium is a
radically different Theatre from a
traditional planetarium instead of
having all the seats facing the center
with a star projector in the center like
the old-school planetariums we have we
have a tilted theater that's angled at
30 degrees there's something like
stadium seating server is facing in the
same direction they're able to see
images and really cover the entire dome
and immerse the audience the original
Morrison actually made history with one
of the first significant American star
projectors it was a completely unique
optical design that created pinpoint
stars over the entire original Morrison
planetarium dome we're doing things very
differently now instead of using actual
mechanical devices and lenses to create
individual star points which only allows
you to see the stars has never appeared
from Earth we're instead designing
things using video projectors and
commodity graphics cards in order to
create a very flexible digital
planetarium environment we're using six
video projectors to cover the entire
surface of our 75 foot diameter down and
those individual projectors are driven
by actually three separate clusters of
computers that we have very down in the
basement underneath the planetarium and
those three clusters allow us to
transition seamlessly between different
sources so we have real-time software
running on one cluster a different
collection of real-time software running
on another and then a playback software
running on the third one of the
challenges in a contemporary planetarium
going digital like this is that there
are different measures of the success of
how well you've done in creating an
image that covers this entire down
resolution is one we have about 3600 by
3600 image that we project over the
entire dome so one of the compromises
that contemporary domes make is
selecting a optimal resolution but also
looking at minimizing the internal
reflections and getting the most
contrast are the projectors that we can
one of the things that the new
technology allows us to do
that is near and dear to my heart
because I'm actually an astronomer
flight training is instead of looking at
the stars as if appear from the night
sky being able to fly through the stars
and actually go outside the Milky Way
galaxy look at the structure of the
large-scale structure of the universe in
terms of scientific discoveries about
the universe one of the great changes
that's taking place over the last decade
or so are the incredibly detailed
surveys of the large-scale structure of
the universe the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey is one of the most significant in
that it's viewing a tremendous fraction
of the sky and actually finding galaxies
there are literally billions of
light-years away that allows us to trace
out the structure of the universe at a
scale that we've never been able to
achieve before so we're also looking at
ways of incorporating up-to-the-minute
data in our presentations for example
NASA is looking at ways of having school
groups analyze parts of Mars because
it's too much work for the limited
number of planetary geologists out there
we could actually bring a classroom in
here that's had a chance to analyze a
portion of Mars and then fly them up to
that part of the planet so they can see
where they've been doing work on the
planet Mars in context of the entire
globe so we're also looking at ways that
we can use the planetarium to connect
with researchers who are out in the
field so we can actually fly up to
Madagascar and then talk to one of our
researchers who is studying the ant
species in that part of the world
actually at one point and give a
presentation to some of our trustees and
you just had the computer software up
and running with just tracking the space
station as it orbited the earth and my
time came to present and as we pulled
away from the space station we saw that
it was right over the Amazon and you can
actually see it the resolution we were
shining deforestation through the Amazon
and it was a very striking moment for
all of us in the room because just
serendipitously we were looking at very
important messages that were actually
gonna be trying to convey here at the
Academy we're opening up the doors to
Sciences other than astronomy as well
because we're using digital images we
can just as easily be flying through a
model of a DNA molecule or the structure
of
faultline in california we can look at
all kinds of science data sets that were
never open to a traditional planetarium
you